our special coverage of race for justice
continues with the new CBS News poll
showing how Americans view on racial
discrimination are shifting more than
half of Americans believe that white
people have a better chance of getting
ahead in today's society that's compared
with black people and now that's up 13
points from 2015 nationwide protests
against inequality are encouraging more
people have discussions not only about
race but also white privilege Robyn
D'Angelo is a sociologist and she's
author of this book white fragility why
it's so hard for white people to talk
about racism I love this title she joins
us with the author of how to be an
anti-racist CBS News contributor Abram X
kandi both of them join us this morning
good to see you both Robin I'm gonna
start with you in your book you write
this unless white people have ongoing an
intentional study there attend their
opinions will be uninformed and ignorant
I read that and I thought whoa very
blunt language so I would like you to
explain what white privilege is exactly
and why white people have such a hard
time seeing it because it's so clear to
most black people I know certainly and
thank you for having me white privilege
is the automatic taken-for-granted
advantage bestowed upon white people as
a result of living in a society based on
the premise of white as the human ideal
and that from its founding established
white advantage as a matter of law and
today as a matter of policy and practice
and it doesn't matter if you agree with
it if you want it if you even are aware
of it
it's 24/7 365 and one of the reasons why
it's so hard for white people to see it
well there are many reasons but one is
it it serves us not to see it we come to
feel entitled to that advantage we're
told that we deserve it and that we
earned it and we take great umbrage when
that is challenged you write to Robin in
the book that kids from the age between
3 and 4 are intuitively taught that
being white is better that you are
superior I thought that that was an
interesting thing but I find many white
Americans today say
and I struggled too I don't have white
privilege what are you talking about and
I'm really clear that I'm not saying
that white people don't struggle or face
barriers or work hard but there's a
major barrier in this society racism
that we don't struggle with and not
struggling against that barrier actually
helps us navigate the the barriers that
we do struggle with you grew up in
poverty how has being white shaped how
you experience poverty and how you get
out of poverty if you do get out of
poverty
again it's not saying that that white
Americans don't work hard but it's it's
a bit like being a fish in a current
that impacts the outcome of that work
there there's a kind of moving along
that amplifies that work and for people
of color for black people you're
swimming against a current
and we're both working we're both
swimming but there's such a different
impact on the outcome of that effort
what are the questions that you think
white Americans should be asking these
days and I say this because I don't know
any black friend of mine that hasn't
gotten calls from white people all
around saying I don't know what to do I
want to help I want to be supportive a
black male friend of mine in Texas said
for the first time he was invited on the
company retreat and he's been there ten
years with you know his co-workers
seeking him out one of the questions
white Americans should be asking well I
think many white Americans claim they
believe in racial equality so the way
you put that to the test is by asking
questions questions about racial
disparities so so why is it that unarmed
black people are killed by police too
many times and an armed white people are
simply arrested why is it in Minneapolis
that black people are 20% of the
population but 60% of the victims of
police shootings why is it that the
black unemployment rate is twice as high
as the one unemployment rate
there's only two answers either there's
something wrong with black people
there's something superior about white
people or recently
Abram you've said that to get to end
white privilege you have to you have to
deal with racism first right yes Robin
you know talked about it it is critical
for for white people for people in
general to stop denying their their
racist ideas to stop denying the ways in
which policies have benefited them to
stop denying their racism and to realize
that actually the heartbeat of racism
itself is denial and the sound of that
heartbeat is I'm not racist Robin do you
believe that that the white folks
actually care about racial injustice it
doesn't appear that we do if you look at
what it takes to wake us up when you
look at the explosion of Umbridge white
people take from the simple claim that
black lives matter from somebody
respectfully going down on their knee
all of the outrage about that and then
it takes us literally seen a man being
murdered in front of our eyes to wake us
up you know that's a really high price
to pay for our enlightenment and it's
just you know I wonder what will happen
when all the cameras go away and there's
another issue in front of us you know if
we don't put something in place to keep
our attention and our focus here I mean
the status quo of our society is racism
and it's comfortable for white people
and so we're not going to get there from
a place of white comfort we're gonna
have to get mighty uncomfortable and
inconvenienced and it appears to me that
in you know 20 years of working with
white people that if it requires
anything of us like discomfort or
inconvenience we don't seem to be
particularly motivated to do anything
Robyn D'Angelo Abram X Kennedy thank you
both for being with us